when you decide to move to the cloud one
of the first things you have to do
is give them your credit card that's
because they're giving you access to a
massive network of computers worth
billions upon billions of dollars when
you write inefficient code on your own
computer it's usually not a big deal the
cpu fan might spin a little faster or
things might run slower when you run out
of ram
but in the cloud it's a whole different
ball game that recursive function you
wrote can now scale infinitely around
the globe
blowing up cpu cores and melting solid
state drives in the process
and someone is going to have to pay for
that mess in today's video we'll look at
a real life story about how a startup
just days away from launch racked up a
72 thousand dollar google cloud bill
stand it's gone didn't do too well it's
gone poof
we'll find out how that's even possible
but more importantly we'll look at ways
to prevent something like that from
happening to you
if you're new here like and subscribe
then let's get right into it
imagine spending months pouring blood
sweat and tears into your startup
you're just days away from the big
launch doing some final testing here and
there
your product is ready to go you just
need to scrape some data from the web to
enrich the user experience
you throw together some ad-hoc code to
get the job done dockerize it
then deploy it to a serverless platform
like google cloud run
it only needs to run for a few hours so
you deploy it then call it a night
you wake up to a couple of interesting
emails our firebase project was upgraded
from the free plan
to the pay-as-you-go plan we must have
enabled an api that requires billing
which automatically upgraded the plan
not to worry we already have a budget
alert in place oh no
the next email tells us our seven dollar
budget has been exceeded
the third email tells us our credit card
was declined i wonder why that would be
let's open the billing panel in google
cloud no god please
no no a bill of over five thousand
dollars in just a few hours
it has to be a mistake let's refresh the
page and pray
no no five minutes later the bill's at
fifteen thousand dollars
after twenty minutes twenty five
thousand dollars the final bill settled
up after about two hours just short of
seventy two thousand
increasing your startups burn rate by
about six hundred dollars per minute
no if you're a bootstrap startup you
might as well make it ten million
dollars
to make matters even worse this company
had multiple products
with multiple google cloud projects to
manage them because things got out of
control so quickly
they had to disable all of their
projects and that's the story of how one
little recursive function took down an
entire business
i declare
bankruptcy luckily the story doesn't end
there
the company immediately contacted google
cloud to make them aware of the issue
and let them know that they did not
intend to purchase this much computing
power
after 10 days of deliberation google did
the not evil thing
and credited the entire 72 thousand
dollar bill that must have been a huge
relief for the company and was a big win
for independent developers around the
world
but keep in mind there's no guarantee
you'll get the same kind of credit when
you rack up a massive bill the best
strategy
is to not rack up a massive bill in the
first place however that's easier said
than done
i've actually racked up two massive
bills myself one time
i accidentally exposed my aws api key in
a public git repo
a few months later i had a 5 000 aws
bill because a hacker scraped the key
and then used it to spin up a bunch of
compute instances
luckily they gave me a credit for my
bill as well it is very reassuring that
these big cloud companies would rather
keep you as a long-term customer
than try to bankrupt you over an honest
mistake but a bill of 72 000
is crazy i've never seen a bill get that
high that quickly and we should all be
thanking announced today for sharing
that story with us
check out their web app for a great
example of angular and firebase in the
wild
then let's dive into the technical
reasons for the massive bill and more
importantly
ways to avoid it yourself tip number one
set up a budget alert
even if you're on the free plan of
something or in the free tier once you
deploy code to the cloud there are
different ways you might exceed the free
tier without knowing it
it's not common but it's still always a
good practice to have a budget alert set
on your account globally
the company did this right by setting a
budget for seven dollars
the problem in this case though was that
the cost increased so quickly
an alert will only send you an email it
doesn't actually shut down anything
when the budget has been exceeded it's
actually kind of crazy that there's not
an easy way to shut down services
when the budget has been exceeded that's
been a major criticism of the cloud for
as long as i can remember
however there may be hope in october
2020 aws released a new feature called
budget actions where you can define an
action based on a budget threshold like
shutting down a server once you've spent
too much money
in addition on google cloud you can
listen to budget events with pub sub
and that means you can write a little
bit of code to create a kill switch
that disables billing if the budget is
exceeded now let's move on to the next
tip
do not create infinite loops in the
cloud do not create
infinite loops in the cloud do not
create infinite loops in the cloud
when it comes to serverless computing
everything is event-based
some kind of event happens in the cloud
like an upload to a storage bucket
which triggers a cloud function for
additional back-end work it's really
easy to shoot yourself in the foot here
though
if your function leads to the same event
that triggered it in the first place
for example a cloud function is
triggered by a storage upload
then you upload a file to the storage
bucket again and the function
thus triggering another function and
again and again and forever until the
end of time
or until your bank account is empty
that's what we call an infinite loop and
it's probably
the number one cause for runaway cost
unexpectedly
especially if your infrastructure is
configured to handle huge workloads
that brings me to tip number three don't
configure things to scale when you're
just messing around our startup used a
service called cloud run
which are serverless functions that
support docker containers
by default cloudrun will scale to a max
of 1000 instances
now if we take a look at the
architecture for the web scraper you'll
notice it starts with a manual request
to the cloud run endpoint
each run scrapes url and saves the
results in firestore
then it takes all the links it found in
a scraped webpage and triggers another
cloud run to process them
if we look at this as pseudocode what we
have here is a recursive function
but a recursive function with no
stopping point which leads to stack
overflow
or in this case cloud overflow which is
a brand new word that i just coined
because the infrastructure was set up to
scale it resulted in a 116 billion reads
to the database and 33 million writes
along with 16 000 hours of cloud run
compute time
the moral of the story is to understand
how different services scale
and configure them to not scale if you
don't need that functionality
in the case of cloud run if the max
instance option was set to 1
instead of 1 000 their bill would have
been 72 dollars
instead of 72 000 but in production you
likely do want things to scale and
sometimes you won't know how bad an
issue is
until your app does scale which brings
me to tip number four
consider how algorithm complexity
affects your cloud computing usage a
while back i made a video
about how to not get a 30 000 firebase
bill which was another case study about
a company that went viral
and a flawed data model caused their
bill to accelerate exponentially
allow me to explain they built a
crowdfunding app and in the app
they calculate the total amount donated
to a crowdfunding cause
they perform the calculation client side
by reading all the donations from the
database for that cause
now let's imagine you have five people
who donated to a cause and a hundred
visitors to that page
that would equal 500 document reads now
let's imagine you have a hundred
thousand visitors
that'd be about 500 000 reads which
still isn't too bad
but now let's imagine you have 5 000
donations to a cause
multiply that by 100k users and you now
have 500 million document reads or in
other words
at the current traffic level each new
donation adds an additional hundred
thousand document reads to the total
workload
it just doesn't scale well a better
option would have been to aggregate the
data on the backend with a cloud
function
rather than calculate the total client
side it could be done on the back end
so that each visitor only has to read
one document instead of 5 000 documents
now i realize stories like this are
pretty alarming but firestore is
actually very inexpensive
and because it's so easy to use you may
not realize you're making a bad data
modeling choice until it's too late
using the right data model can go a long
way and you can learn more about that in
my data modeling course
but yet another way you might experience
runaway cost is by failing to secure
your app
and that leads me to tip number five
make sure your app is secure
most importantly make sure to protect
any secret api keys
like i mentioned earlier exposing my aws
api key on github
allowed a hacker to take full control
over my account but there are many other
ways you might fail to secure your
infrastructure
when it comes to firestore you need to
define security rules to define who has
access to what in the database and of
course i have a full course on that as
well
leaving the database open means anybody
could read or write to it
not only does that leave you vulnerable
to a data breach but also to hackers
that just want to drive up your costs
the same principle goes for any
application that is available on the web
when you have a service that's available
on the internet it means someone can
find that url
and exploit it i'm going to go ahead and
wrap things up there please make sure to
like and subscribe and if you're
building an app with firebase or google
cloud
consider becoming a pro member at
fireship io thanks for watching and i
will see you in the next one